- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 320
of The #AskGaryVee show,
and this is a very exciting episode,
because the person that will
be dialing the questions
and getting to the
questions today is India,
our very own India, who's on her last day
after seven years at Vayner
Media, moving to Portland.
So everybody in Portland,
if you see her, stop her,
take a selfie, post it on social, tag me.
But fun fact, for a lot
of you that don't know,
India was a superstar.
You know how Ari Gold actually
became the star of Entourage,
but that wasn't the purpose?
There was absolutely a time in 2016?
- '16 I think?
- In 2016, where India was
my main cohost of the show,
when it was a completely call-in show,
or take questions from the internet show,
and the reason I had
to get her off the show
was it became clear to me that
she'd become bigger than me,
and I wasn't really
willing to deal with that,
and has just been an
amazing part of our team,
and I love her very much, and
it's fun to have you here.
Do you know the first episode you were on?
- I think it was like
number 20 or something.
- 20?
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
So, it's fun to have you here.
For all the new cats, go back
and watch some of those shows,
like episode 30 to 200, or 150,
and you'll see a bunch of
India and I interactions.
It's a lot of fun, so thanks for being on.
Also exciting, we have
the marketing fire power
behind NASCAR,
an organization that we've,
at the VaynerX level,
have worked with a little bit,
but more importantly,
just my love of sports
and marketing, I'm
always looking for guests
that make that cross,
so it's super exciting
to have you guys here.
Why don't you guys introduce yourselves
to the Vayner Nation,
and before you do that,
put in your phone numbers
on YouTube and Facebook
if you wanna call in and ask questions,
I'm gonna go pretty question-heavy here,
especially if you're
into sports marketing,
into NASCAR itself, or marketing itself,
as you start listening to the framework.
Ladies first.
- Thank you.
I'm Jill Gregory, I'm the
chief marketing officer
at NASCAR, I've been at NASCAR,
Steve Phelps here hired
me 10-plus years ago.
Big fan of the sport,
but was not growing up,
and I think the potential
that we've got at NASCAR
to keep growing is huge,
so thanks for having us.
- [Gary] Of course, Jill.
- And I'm Steve Phelps, I'm
the president of NASCAR,
and I've been with NASCAR almost 14 years,
I think 14 years next week.
I did grow up a NASCAR fan,
worked at the NFL for almost 14 years,
and then transitioned over to NASCAR,
and it's a phenomenal place
to work and a great sport.
- Let's lean into this,
because I think, for
everybody who's watching,
to make a connection point
with the Vayner Nation
and you guys, I'm obsessed.
My whole last decade of my
career is to build a machine,
this marketing communications machine,
to buy nostalgic businesses and brands.
And what's been really fun,
being 43 and loving sports,
is there's been incredible
patterns in NASCAR,
in culture, as a net sport,
over the last 50 years,
for that matter.
I wanna go into that origin story.
Where'd you grow up, and
why were you a NASCAR fan?
- Sure, so, I grew up in Vermont.
I see on India's book there,
we've got the Vermont sticker.
Thank you for that.
There're not a lot of us there.
- Hold on, I apologize.
India, why do you have a Vermont sticker?
- I lived there for four
years in Bennington, Vermont,
when I was in college.
- God dammit, I forgot that.
Okay, keep going.
- I grew up in Burlington, Vermont.
So, my dad was a big NASCAR fan.
There was a track about
15 miles from our house,
which is no longer there,
called Catamount Speedway.
- [Gary] Oh, Catamount.
- And so, I went there the first time
when I was five years old
with my brother and my dad,
and my father was nice enough to tell me,
you absolutely have to root
for the Vermont drivers.
No one from New York, no one from Quebec,
you have to root for--
- No Massholes?
- No. (laughs)
- [Gary] Who was your favorite driver?
- My favorite driver at five
was the driver of the number five,
white number five, 'cause
it was speed racer.
Unfortunately, he was from Quebec,
so my dad forbid me for
rooting for that driver.
His name was Cabana.
- Steve, you know what's super interesting
about this, me and Mickey just smiled,
a lot of people, even
just a couple days ago,
always ask me why do I put up number five
when I take photos with people?
Actually, when I chose the Jets
as my favorite team at five,
my favorite player was
Pat Leahy, the kicker,
who wore number five, and to this day,
everything, five is very,
it's funny that you
were that age when you,
that's wild, that's funny.
So, go ahead.
- I'm the fifth president of NASCAR,
so maybe there's a five connection.
- [Gary] Yeah, I like that, numbers game.
Fun facts.
- But yes,
NASCAR, like most sports,
very generational, generational transfer,
so I started with going to the racetrack,
and the sights and the
smells and the sounds
of what it's like to go to a NASCAR track,
it was a short track,
as I said, doesn't exist anymore there,
but that was my first love of the sport,
and it grew, and so I ebbed
and flowed a little bit.
When I got into college,
I really got back into it,
and then got in the sports world.
I remember a time when Paul Tagliabue,
who was the commissioner when I was there,
Paul, he brought me up, and he said,
"Hey I hear you're our
resident NASCAR expert,"
and I gave him a tutorial on NASCAR,
so it was pretty cool.
- That's rad.
And how about for you,
you come into the role,
were you CMO right away,
10 or 11 years ago, or first in marketing,
and grew up within it?
- Yeah, no, we created a group
when I first started at NASCAR,
designed to, I mean,
this was, like I said,
quite a few years ago, but it was designed
to help the drivers with their brands,
and so prior to us creating that group,
and it was probably a
very primitive version
of what we all do today,
but it's trying to get
these drivers to understand
that it's not just about what
the did on the racetrack,
'cause I think their whole mindset was,
I get in the car, I go
fast, and I go home,
I sign a couple autographs,
and I call it a day.
And obviously today,
what they do in the car
is almost secondary.
I mean, you gotta win on the track,
and you've gotta be a competitor,
but the things that they do on social,
engaging with fans.
- [Gary] Sponsor events.
- Way more important than it used to be.
So, we started that.
When I joined NASCAR,
just a three-person team,
and now it's grown into our
entire marketing organization
is built on those driver brands.
- For everybody who's
listening, knowing the sport,
what is a good three-minute rant
on the current state of NASCAR
for people that are
considering it, or watching it.
Can you give me a little three minutes
on the current state of the sport?
- You want me to rant?
- Go ahead, rant.
- So, I would say, we have
been, we had this period of time
over the three to four years,
where I would say five or six
of our most popular drivers retired.
And so, when that happened,
we knew we had to
refresh the driver base--
- Yeah, it's funny, for
everybody who's listening,
knowing what we talk a lot about,
it happened to the NBA after
the Jordan, Bird, Magic thing.
My favorite comp for this is wrestling,
since McMahon controls the narrative,
but it still comes down to
the actors and the athletes,
and so after Hogan and
Macho and Andre the Giant,
there's a gap, and then
The Rock and Stone Cold
come along, and it reboots.
- Same thing for us.
So, we had--
- Dale Jr.
- Yeah, Junior, Tony Stewart, Jeff Gordon,
Carl Edwards, Danica Patrick.
Those are big names in our sport,
and many had been around for two decades,
and so for us, like any
other brand, any other sport,
you refresh the brand.
So, we got a phenomenal
group of young drivers,
this crop is both the largest,
in the skills, the personalities,
the authenticity of who they are,
and the great news is, they can win.
You can have a great
personality, be very charismatic,
our fans want the drivers to win.
It helps develop their--
- This is a debate,
and pontificating that
I have with you guys.
So, everybody who's listening,
my incredible observation
of the next 20, 30 years,
is that the direct social scale does,
for the first time ever,
create a debate of winning on the field
being a direct attribute,
because I do think that we're
gonna be able to see 360,
no different than people who
are vloggers and influencers,
and they're not winning anything,
can America or the world become fascinated
by a human, just based on their
backstory, their life story?
By the way, you're talking to a sports fan
who actually drops his
teams when they win.
I stopped being a Yankee
fan and Rangers fan
after Rangers won in '94
and the Yankees won in '96,
so I'm in it for the climb.
If I got behind a racer, young,
I'd probably love them two
or three or four years--
- [Jill] You want the underdog.
- I want the process of trying to win,
more so the winner.
But nonetheless, to your point,
winning has always been the
variable for max popularity,
but you guys have a pedigree sport.
One thing that interesting about you guys,
the Elliott kid now, Dale Jr.,
I remember watching that very carefully,
as a casual fan just knowing.
When you are a second
generation of an icon,
you definitely have a pretty big fan base
before you've won,
which I always feel super compassionate
and empathetic towards that kid,
'cause the pressure's impossible.
- Well, you look at Dale
Jr. early in his career,
and I think part of why he has transformed
into such a great media personality
is that early on, you have
to think that pressure
was a lot for him to handle,
and I think as he continued to get older
and then even now, when he's in the booth,
broadcasting races, he's
much more comfortable
with his role and his legacy,
and you can see that in how he interacts.
- Yeah, it's a tough piece.
I mean, Petty's kid raced, right?
And like not as successfully of a career.
It's tough.
- Richard Petty, King,
no one's gonna, that's a level--
- Have you met the King?
- I have not, I'd love to.
- [Jill] We need to make that happen.
- [Gary] What is he, 43?
- 43.
- See, to me, that's interesting.
The fact that I know that
just speaks to how much of
an impact he had on culture.
Yeah, I mean listen, any time
your dad is known in anything
as the fucking King, you're in deep shit.
Let's just get to the punchline.
Like, that's gonna be a problem.
Bad news Xander, marketing
is gonna be tough for you.
I'm kidding, Dustin.
All right, let's keep going.
- I think the interesting thing, too,
so you talk about these
young stars that we have,
and authentic and charismatic,
you take the guy who currently runs
for Richard Petty
Motorsports, Bubba Wallace,
African-American kid,
phenomenal personality,
and not afraid to show his emotions,
not afraid, I mean he's
funny, he's just a cool guy.
- [Gary] Wanna get some nerdy ones in.
Keep going, I'm listening.
- You've got
Chase Elliott, you have Danny Suarez,
who's from Mexico, he's in the series.
So, we've got these young up-and-coming
winners on the racetrack
that can wheel a race car
that's resonating with our fan base.
So, right now, I believe this is,
maybe I'm not an expert to say this,
but just my own eye
test, I think the racing
that we have right now on our racetracks
is the best we've ever had.
- You're also going through
a lot of innovation.
One of things that I admire from afar
that the sport's doing is, look,
by losing those big names
by different TV dynamics
over the last 15 years,
10 years, we're not at the apex of NASCAR
as we sit here today in
the way that we were.
You've been there 14 years, you're a fan,
what is the last real
white-hot era, would you say?
- I would say probably '07 to '09.
- Yeah.
Was that when Nextel was--
- [Jill] Nextel came in
in 2004 with that season.
- So, what's really interesting is,
this is something I yell
about with baseball,
and I think they're finally
starting, and I have empathy,
when you start getting
into 200 years and shit,
but you guys are really innovating.
You guys are doing things that,
I kinda slightly am curious
what the old school 30, 40,
50-year fan is thinking,
when you start changing sports,
heck, I'm a diehard football fan,
and I weirdly don't
want an 18-game schedule
for one weird reason:
It throws off me understanding
how to calibrate stats.
So, change is hard,
but you guys have absolutely
shown the willingness
and have announced more changes to come,
and from a business standpoint,
I'm always innovate or die,
that has not been the historic
point of view of sports
at all, and I feel like you guys,
I'll let you talk, but
outside of rogue leagues,
not rogue leagues, other leagues,
most of basketball's
innovation came from the ABA.
Most of the innovation for the NFL
came from the USFL or the XFL.
It usually comes when
you see a pop of that.
You guys are doing it to yourself.
- We are.
For us, we think it was important
to do exactly that, because...
existing fans and then new fans,
fans you're trying to
get to watch our sport,
we need to make sure
that they're entertained,
and we've been criticized about
hey, you're chasing the entertainment,
and you're chasing, the answer is yes,
it needs to be compelling.
And so we have created
things like stage racing,
so three different segments of our races,
and then there are points
you can get as a driver
that help you get to our playoffs,
so playoffs, new concept
for us that we introduced.
Segments, new concept that we introduced.
The race car itself, and
what we're doing today,
and where we're going with
the race car in the future.
- What's been the reaction to that?
I mean, it's always pro
and con, I'm curious.
- I promise I'll let you
talk, but I get excited.
- You grew up a fan, Jill didn't.
This is appropriate.
- No, I had three cousins that dragged me
to the local dirt tracks.
They're all just mad at me still today
that I have this job and they don't,
so shout out to the crew.
- I think, for us,
a lot of the things
that we have introduced,
typically it's a 50-50, right?
So, you have half your fans
that say hey I like that,
and half don't.
And so what we've been able to do,
because we do a lot of research
and a lot of analytics and insights
in terms of what we
believe is going to work,
and sometimes, fans don't
know what is going to work.
They're kind of stuck in
hey, this is what I like,
and so change is hard.
- If I listen to my customer,
I would've made a faster horse.
And you guys are, I'm always
like listen to the customer,
but then I always counter it with that,
that's just the truth.
- So for us, it's kind
of what happens, right?
So, we've been able to, in
a lot of different things
that we've done, so playoffs,
more than eight out of 10 of our fans
say hey, that's a great
idea, started at 50.
Stage racing, started at 50,
now we're well up over 80%,
so we're always trying
to listen to the fan
and kinda iterate around it.
- Before we get to this call,
what's been the most interesting thing
in the last year or two
from a marketing standpoint?
It can be completely anything,
it can be a tactic you did on Instagram,
it can be a brand coming to you,
just hot take, some of
the interesting stuff
on the intersection of
marketing and NASCAR.
- A lot of what we work with you guys on,
I mean the explosion of content,
we would never say that it was good
that we had the retirement
of all those big stars.
That clearly was not the case.
- Adversity leads to innovation.
- Right, and given where
the world is going,
these young drivers are
eager to prove themselves,
they're out there, they're social natives,
they are ready to take on the challenge,
so we would've had a harder
time I think adapting--
- With the OGs.
- Yeah, with those veteran drivers
that are like you know what,
I know what I need to do,
so I'm good.
- This has been working
for me for 20 years,
screw you, Jill.
You Tweet, get out of my face.
- I'm busy, I have a lot
of engagements, yeah.
- Who's this?
- Beanz and Rice.
- Is the name of the person?
- Uh-huh.
- Okay.
- With a Z, Beanz with a Z.
- You got it.
(phone ringing)
Beanz and Rice with a Z?
Understood.
- [Beanz] Hello?
- Beanz!
You're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with the NASCAR crew.
- [Beanz] Holy fuck!
I literally had my heart drop!
- Yep!
I'm glad you're on Beanz, I really am,
and I love that you use a Z
at the end of the Beanz part.
I think that's very clever.
So, what's your question?
- [Beanz] Wow, I can't even tell you
how much that means to me.
I'll get right to it.
Thank you guys for having
me, but my question is,
was NASCAR, I'm not really
into that sport personally,
but I'm wondering how the
needs have changed over time,
how maybe like some of the challenges
that y'all faced in the '90s or the 2000s,
what were they, and
also, what are the needs
and challenges facing y'all
today, and how they differ?
- Beanz, real quick, just
'cause I love this stuff,
what sports, if any, are you into?
- [Beanz] Basketball, but
really, I'm a musician,
so I'm not a huge sports head,
and I'm like really far
from being a NASCAR fan,
but with much respect, I have
a lot of respect for y'all.
- That's great.
And why basketball in a world
where you're so hard music?
Did you play it, is it your friends?
I'm just curious of the
mapping of the fandom.
- Yeah, I think just culture, Jordans,
which I'm now realizing you hate.
(all laugh)
- [Jill] Gonna get to that
Kevin Love conversation.
- Yeah, playing like
pickup games at school
and playing in middle school on the team.
- I appreciate it, Beanz.
So, what are the challenges?
Let's just break it down.
I'll DJ Beanz's question,
'cause I'm curious for myself actually.
When it was at its best
moments, highest reigning stars,
white heat moment, 'cause I
don't think you're at your down
right now, especially when
I look at it historically,
but in comparison to
your white heat moment,
what were the challenges then,
and what are the current
challenges in your perspective?
- Yeah, I think that challenges,
I think there were a lot of
opportunities in the '90s,
and there was kind of
an explosion of NASCAR.
A lot of it had to do with
taking what was considered
to be a Southern sport
and expanding across the country.
- Yeah, Beanz, just to give you context,
back in the day, this was like,
oh that's that country thing.
It was a very specific geographic.
By the way, just to put into context,
no different than lacrosse
was a Northeast thing,
there's a lot of these things.
Surfing, nobody's surfing in Oklahoma.
There's a lot of that, but
it was, as a huge sport,
it was unbelievably regional.
- I agree, so I think there
were different challenges,
there were media challenges,
because NASCAR races were
on 12, 13 different--
- Networks?
- Networks.
- And reconsolidated the media deal.
- Media rights in '01.
But just kind of the expansion
in this country.
- Was NASCAR's first
national boost Worldwide of Sports?
That's where I, as a real young kid,
and probably happening even before I was,
that's probably why I know Petty.
It feels like Worldwide
of Sports, was that?
Or Daytona 500?
- I think Daytona 500.
So the '79 Daytona 500,
there was snowstorm.
Big fight.
- Oh, right, I remember that!
- Punches being thrown, brothers involved,
it was like the seminal moment.
- It made evening news from everywhere?
America's like wait, those
fuckers fight on the track?
- It was the first live broadcast as well,
so a lot of things came together.
- Was the fight staged?
- No.
- It was not.
- [Gary] That would've been way better.
- Our drivers get pissed.
- They were just pissed.
They put the helmet on, their
brain leaks out the side.
- They still fucking jump out
and throw their helmet at each other.
Tony Stewart was great for that stuff.
- [Jill] Really good.
- He was angry a lot.
- Yeah, that's how he rolled.
So, that was a challenge, what about now?
- So I think now,
we've certainly got a number of challenges
that we're overcoming.
I think the retirement
thing was certainly,
but I think just people--
- Was the TV switch, right,
'cause Fox was your big play
in that white heat moment,
and I don't recall.
- So, we had Fox, and
then we had NBC, TNT,
and then we had switched back to ESPN,
and then we are now Fox and NBC.
So, we had great media partners,
but I think it's people's time,
we need to make sure that we're relevant,
and so that's why the
changes to the racing itself,
because we want it to be
as exciting as it can be,
so we want a race at the
tracks that people wanna go to,
to see the racing that we wanna see,
we want close competitive
side-by-side racing,
guys mixing it up on the track,
and in some cases, off the track.
But people's time is valuable.
- And you better have a
compelling story to break through,
'cause there's so much.
- When I look at how
much time is being spent
watching my videos on YouTube,
the first thing I always
go to, I'm like, my God,
20 years ago, that was going
into TV shows, magazines.
That's one little me, just me.
And you start thinking--
- I agree, so you take a look
at television ratings, right?
So, our TV ratings this
year, all sports down 9%,
just fewer people watching television.
- [Gary] Yeah, the end.
- Cord Cutters, Never Cords, Cord Shavers,
they're just not watching TV.
- Or a generation, my
little guy, six-year-old,
would rather watch a
baseball game on his iPad
with updated moments.
He has it on, but he only
watches it on the iPad,
'cause he likes to see all
the data around the at-bat.
The game is literally
on, he's not watching it,
'cause he's watching in
realtime on the iPad.
- So, you're adapting to changing needs,
and we're doing the same thing.
So, for us, our ratings
this year were plus three,
so are we back and killing it?
We're coming back, and
we're onto something,
and it's that young drivers.
- And with fewer people
watching TV in general.
- [Gary] Beanz, I appreciate the call.
- [Beanz] I also wanted
to jump in and ask,
does that compel you to try
to convert maybe viewers
who are obsessed with another sport,
like hardcore basketball
fans or hardcore soccer fans,
do you ever take the
time to try to convert,
or are you just really focused
on the people who already like NASCAR?
- The Beanz part of your
question was just okay,
the Rice part of your
question was amazing.
(all laugh)
- So, I'll take this,
and Jill can jump in.
I think we wanna convert people...
where there's fertile ground, right?
So, if someone is just into basketball,
we have a ton of crossover
with other sports,
so believe it or not, there
are folks that watch golf
that also love NASCAR.
- [Gary] That makes a lot
of sense to me, actually.
- The biggest crossover
for us actually is the NFL.
- [Gary] That also makes sense.
- That crossover for us is huge.
- What about college football,
or you don't score that?
- [Steve] College football for sure.
- To me, that feels super intuitive,
the epicenter of college
football sits in a demo--
- In the Southeast, no question.
For us, we need to make sure--
- [Gary] Is that Beanz?
- [India] I don't think so.
- That we're nurturing
the folks that we have,
'cause we wanna keep that hardcore fan,
but then we need to find this
younger, more diverse fan,
and we're working hard
to do that.
- Any sport
that isn't thinking
about youth and diversity
is looking to not win 2030.
- [Jill] And storylines matter, right?
People want storylines.
- [Gary] And you wanna see
somebody that looks like you.
- That's exactly right.
- The best thing to happen to
baseball was Jackie Robinson.
I mean, anyway, let's move on.
It's really cool, it's
really interesting to me,
because also one thing that I think
people are starting to
understand, because of Esports,
and really, let's call it what it is,
the growth of, go ahead.
The growth of proper
football, soccer, in America,
it's really interesting
to understand that, good?
- [Jill On Recording]
And storylines matter.
- Hey, Beanz.
- [Beanz] Hey, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(people chattering)
Okay, great. (laughs)
(phone dialing)
Watching Esports and soccer grow
reminds us, like I said in the meeting,
or actually in a prior meeting,
the heavyweight champion of the world
was the most famous athlete.
Horse racer, horses were more
famous that football players.
- [Steven] Hello?
- Steven?
- [Steven] Yes?
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show
with the NASCAR crew.
- All right, Gary Vee!
How are you today?
- I'm well, say hello to the NASCAR crew.
- [Steven] Yeah, how you doing, Steve,
how you doing, Jill?
- [Jill] Doing great, how are you, Steven?
- [Steven] Well, I think
you made a great segue
into my question, it's
talking about Esports there,
Gary Vee, so we got a driver
right now, William Byron,
driver of the number 24 car,
who made his start in racing in E-racing,
and you got a big event this week on NBC
where you televise iRacing, E-racing,
for the very first time.
What does the sport, the future of that,
look like for NASCAR?
- [Gary] That's a great question.
- Go ahead.
- Go ahead, Jill.
- It's a great question.
I think that the fact that William Byron
sat on the pole the Daytona
500, and did no racing
until he did iRacing,
which was our simulated Esports product,
is a story that hasn't been told.
You could start
doing that today
- That's an insane story.
- And that's the pinnacle of our sport.
- I'm not sure there is another sport
that will have that happen.
- [Jill] You can't go play Madden
and then go play for the Jets.
Well, maybe you could play for the Jets.
- No, you're right, I mean I wish I could,
I'm not good enough for Madden either.
No, that's right, that
is actually remarkable.
And like actually, look, I
think that soccer matters
in America 'cause of FIFA.
I was there when the first FIFA
Sega Genesis game came out.
And I bought it, 'cause I bought
all video games back then,
and none of my friends wanted to play,
'cause nobody gave a shit
about soccer in 1994.
And then slowly but surely,
FIFA got bigger and bigger and bigger.
I mean, but again, back to that point,
you're not playing for
Liverpool after being awesome.
The fact that you guys have that
might actually be the singular unlock.
- Well, and I think the
hardest thing for us
is you can't go play
NASCAR in the backyard.
- Back to the guy who said basketball,
I was thinking that.
- Exactly.
So, this is a way that you can participate
and understand how our sport works
and get to be good at it
without having to go to a racetrack.
We want everybody to come to races.
- Jill, I apologize.
Did you guys think that
that was gonna happen
when you first rolled out the program,
or was that even too big
of a leap for you guys
that somebody's gonna sit
at home, get great at this,
and then actually be a fucking player?
- Well, I don't think
we could've never scripted that ourselves.
We get accused of
scripting a lot of things.
- Did you believe that
that was gonna happen?
- No, no way.
- I did not.
- And he's driving Jeff Gordon's car,
this kid, William Byron,
who we know was doing nothing at age 15,
picked up iRacing.
Nothing in the sport.
He's a great kid.
And he's driving one
of the most iconic cars
at the highest level, and so I think that
the more people that understand
and get exposed to NASCAR through iRacing.
- Jill, I'll be very honest with you,
I'm not sure I made the connection point
to the question, Steven,
thank you for asking.
I actually think that's
the complete unlock.
It's crazy!
That will capture the imagination
of an enormous amount of girls and boys.
The only place you can go
from video game to actual
profession is NASCAR.
I actually think that's true.
- Well, I think that the
other component to that too,
and Jill alluded to it,
you can't go in the backyard to do it,
but you can do it online,
and you can do iRacing,
and it is incredible simulated racing.
- Well, clearly, that's the point
that I didn't make the connection on,
which is the product is so good
that the mapping of being great at it
maps enough to real life, that's nuts!
- Well, I think the nice
thing about it too is,
car racing is expensive,
and so you can figure out early and often
whether you're good at it or not,
so you're not spending 10s
of thousands of dollars.
- I've always thought that this
was hockey's biggest issue,
it's expensive to be in youth hockey,
which eliminates a lot of great athletes
from ever getting into the pipe.
- And the fact that NBC
is gonna broadcast it,
I mean, that's gonna be
huge exposure for it,
and that's Steven's question is that
the fact that our media partners
are taking this component
of NASCAR seriously
is gonna be even bigger and
expose more people to it.
- Steven, I appreciate the question.
- [Steven] Yep, no problem!
Thank you very much!
- Thanks for watching the show.
All right, let's get one more in.
That was a great question.
- [Jill] Yeah, it was really good.
- I really gotta tell you,
I think there's something real there.
I think that's something that you have
that is so much of an advantage
compared to any other sport.
- I agree, well, I think
the other thing too
is the people that do iRacing,
they're absolutely nuts about
it, that's the cool thing.
- [India] Guitars Ruin Lives.
- Excuse me?
- Guitars Ruin Lives, but he plays guitar.
- [Josh] This is Josh.
- Josh, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Josh] Okay, it's
happening, shit, all right.
Thanks, let's do this.
What's up, Gary?
- Things are good, please
say hello to Steve and Jill.
- [Josh] Hello, Steve and Jill.
I'm doing my best to hear
you, it's a little quiet,
but I'll bear with it.
Thank you guys.
- No worries.
What's your question?
- [Josh] So, the question,
as I put it forth in the comments there,
was I think it's interesting
looking at sponsorship
as something, I'm no huge NASCAR fan,
so I'm not posing here, but at least,
everybody's familiar with the concept
of the patches being on
them and all that stuff,
and I imagine there's a
lot that has gone into that
as far as drivers and their promoters,
their managers, marketing,
and using that as a
cross-pollination thing culturally,
and business-wise, of course,
trying to drive business,
and I think it's
interesting looking at that
compared to influencer culture
and all the things that you talk about
as far as damning and
whether you're looking at it
from the business angle of a
business using a small service
to promote their agenda or vice versa,
I think that's fascinating, so I'm curious
if your guests could speak a little bit
to that kind of model,
and I guess you could
speak to how that relates
to what influencers should be doing today.
- Well, I think for our drivers,
the sponsors can be in the field of play,
the sponsors are their personal partners,
so it's not slapping a logo on a uniform
or getting a personal services agreement;
they are in the fabric of
what makes these drivers tick,
so I think for us, we've
gotta pay attention to that.
I think where we also kind
of struggle a little bit--
- You mean some of the sponsors
are actually integrated into the product,
but some aren't, right?
- [Jill] No, they aren't, but they are--
- Like the M&M's car,
the most integrated it can be
is he or she is eating
the M&M's during the race.
- Yeah, which may happen.
Dick Trickle used to have
candy in his car, right?
We know the Dick Trickle story.
But your brand is on the
car, your brand is on,
very few brands are on the field.
- And even the NBA, which
has gotten progressive,
obviously soccer in Europe
is probably the only comp.
The NBA has been, I mean that little logo
in the top left is really tipping your toe
in comparison to your point, which,
even soccer, which is at its scale,
a car's much bigger than a jersey.
- Well, and I think the other thing is,
our fans, they're passionate
and they're trained,
they expect sponsorship,
they wanna wear the jacket
with the huge M&M's logo on it,
so that makes our sport
even more valuable.
- I assume, just 'cause I
buy things at garage sales
and sell them, knowing that M&M culture
in collecting is real,
I assume some people
become fan of the driver because of M&M's.
- Oh, absolutely,
especially think about
your five-year-old example,
kids like Kyle Busch 'cause
he drives the M&M's car,
and then they grow up to be
Kyle Busch fans, the candy man.
- Budweiser and Dale, that mattered.
- It was a really good brand fit there.
- Yeah, that was a real good one.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I think that what people don't realize
is this is a huge advantage for NASCAR
in a couple different ways, in my opinion,
but where it really gets interesting
is I think almost every human
is gonna do a sponsored deal in 2040.
I think by the year 2040,
most humans in our society
are going to be in a
place where they'll do
some sort of commercial
transaction through them,
because I think technology
will advance enough.
My dream for my brands is to
actually get the alpha mom
who has 212 followers on Instagram,
but she influences seven
people on her block
or at school, and basically,
I wanna give her a free bottle of wine.
That's what she is worth to my business.
But I wish I could do that now.
There's a lot of dollars that
go into the people finding,
there's not infrastructure.
I think it's crazy, I think
it's not out of the question
that the dynamics we see in NASCAR
actually translate to
people driving in real life,
that if you told my by 2060,
everybody's car was sponsored out,
I'd be like, I understand.
They're not gonna get the kinda numbers
or all the eyeballs that the racers get,
but I think it's really cool,
and I think there's a lot of
clever bridges that can be built.
- Absolutely.
- I appreciate the question.
- [Josh] Thank you so much.
Thank you Gary, I need to take one moment
and just say thank you.
I discovered you about two months ago,
I was watching your
interview with Mr. Love
the other day, and I
do have a lot of things
that he has talked about,
and I want to tell you that
literally listening to
you and your podcast daily
has done more for me than any pill
or any other way that
I have had to medicate
for getting my ass going and
being enthusiastic about life.
And I'm wearing your shoes,
and I got your hoodie!
Thank you.
- You're an amazing dude.
The shoes and hoodies you can return.
That sentence meant the world to me.
Thank you, brother.
- [Josh] Thank you, bye.
- You have something to say
about the Kevin Love podcast?
I've been dying since our business meeting
and now in the podcast.
- It's more lighthearted,
a more lighthearted
piece of the Kevin Love.
I took offense to your comment
that all Warriors fans
are these bandwagons,
Silicon Valley types.
- [Gary] Are you a real Warriors fan?
- I am a real Warriors fan.
Run TMC.
Tim, Mitch, and Chris.
- Yes, listen, there
are real Warrior fans.
Not all are.
But the stunning amount of percentage
of bandwagon Warrior
fans is extraordinary.
And it's not the kids who
get inspired at six, seven,
what am I gonna do there?
I'm actually talking about the--
- [Jill] The court-side seats.
- Forget about they're the
richest people in Silicon Valley
and they can buy it and they're
completely full of shit,
and they like the Lakers 10
years earlier or whatever,
as fans, I don't even know
most of them well enough
to know as humans.
I'm talking about the
masses that are sitting in
12 rows back, who are also quite well-off,
that I actually fully know.
The hundreds of them that I met
during my 2006, seven, eight, nine years,
those years in Silicon Valley every week,
every other week, every month,
and being a sports fan and
wanting to talk about things
besides NerdTech in 2007,
maybe you could find a
San Francisco Giants fan,
'cause they were playing well,
but literally when I
would say things like,
what you think of Monty Ellis?
They were like, who's that?
And then I was like, well
what about the Warriors?
And they're like, who are they?
And I was like, you know
the Golden State Warriors
are here, and they're like, they are?
- Just so you know,
Gary was so passionate
about his lack of knowledge
of any true Warriors fans
that he wanted the Cavs
to win that series,
and he was excited, even
though he's not a Cavs fan.
- That wasn't it.
I'm sorry, you missed the nuance.
It's that I hate Michael Jordan so much
that I've been rooting for LeBron
since he was a high school player.
Tomorrow, there's hype
around a new 15-year-old,
that person will immediately
become somebody I adore,
and hope wins seven championships
so they can be the number one
so Jordan can be, not the next,
to me, Anthony Davis, I actually,
it is literally Nix, and then LeBron,
to win as many rings as possible,
'cause I just hate
Michael Jordan that much.
I genuinely do.
Final points that we didn't
get to, for both of you.
Jill?
- I would say give NASCAR a try.
What you're gonna see is huge competition,
backstories, passion, drama,
and you've got a group of drivers
that's really compelling to watch.
- Actually, I wanna ask you
this, what you just said,
I just saw this, I see a big crossover,
I've had a lot of
friends through the years
that I grew up that like wrestling,
really get into NASCAR
because what you just said.
Stories.
There's some real,
every sport has them, but
there's so much tradition
in NASCAR that A, it's a
second or third generation kid,
or B, it's the first
Mexican-American to do it,
it's the first Asian,
it's the first female,
there's so much tradition that either
you're part of the establishment
or you're breaking ground
into the establishment,
and it always makes
for compelling stories.
- Yes, and with the wide
swath of drivers we have,
they're relatable, so I
think you can find a driver
that you look at and
say, that guy seems cool,
he likes the kinda music I like,
he had the same upbringing I had.
- Including one of the only major sports,
if not the only major sports,
that is place where we
will see females play,
compete at the highest level.
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] Oh, India, you like that?
- [India] I do.
- You're very woke,
India, you're very woke.
So woke.
- She's moving to Portland,
you have to be woke.
- You're just gonna woke your
way to Portland, aren't you?
- I think the cool thing about it too is
our guys, by and large, our
guys aren't prima donnas,
they're just authentic to who they are.
- Oh, the definitely have
that hockey DNA, right?
Everybody always talks about
NASCAR and hockey players.
- I have a theory about that.
My theory about that is these guys,
so you're 17 years old,
you wanna ask this girl
to go to the prom, you're a
national karting champion,
she is going to go with
the backup tight end
to the prom, versus you.
- 100%.
- Every time.
- And so you have to stay grounded,
and that's what these guys are.
They are grounded.
- I actually think NASCAR, hockey,
and some degree baseball's biggest problem
is sometimes they stay too grounded.
I really do.
I think they think of storytelling
or putting out content as showboating
instead of just sharing information.
There's been a lot of guys
that have been able to break through,
and I'm like, that's not showboating.
Educate people how to
change a tire, like I can.
- You'll even see that
when they talk about
success that they have, and they'll say,
they thank everyone else,
but it's not like, hey,
I kicked ass today.
- No, it's the guys
back at the shop, right?
- The shop, or any of the crew guys,
made a great pitstopper.
- That's one of the more
fascinating parts of the sport.
That crew matters.
That gets into my favorite,
I've always used the offensive
line quarterback analogy
with the pit and driver,
the driver's gonna get all the headlines,
but the offensive line really matters.
- Pit crew really matters.
And they're tremendous
athletes, and it's phenomenal.
- I think the pit crew
are better athletes,
like net athletes than the drivers.
Like net, if you just think about--
- [Steve] No question.
- Right?
Like when I looked, this
is common sense debate,
it could be wrong, but when I look at it,
I'm like yeah, they've got like--
- They're jacking up a 3,500-pound car,
they're running around,
changing tires in 10 seconds.
- And the pit's jumping
over, sliding through,
it's like every second matters.
- It does.
- I appreciate you guys being on the show.
- [Jill] Thanks for having us.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Good luck, India!
- [India] Thank you.
- India, any parting shots?
- No, I think I've said
everything I need to say.
- You have been, you've
been crushing content.
- I've been truly trying, yeah.
I learned from the best.
- It's true, the King!
(Steve laughs)
Thanks for listening.
- Oh, we have a new nickname!
- On this episode, we wish
India the Great goodbye,
and we talk NASCAR.